certaines personnes sont intolérantes au
lactose et c'est les empêche de boire du
lait et de digérer certains produits
laitiers
pendant longtemps on s'est demandé
qu'est-ce qui pouvait causer cette
maladie et on pourra imaginer qu'elle
puisse avoir une origine génétique et
bien aujourd'hui on va voir que
l'intolérance au lactose c'est tout le
contraire d'une maladie si vous êtes
toujours capable de boire du lait alors
c'est vous l'anomalie génétique
commençons par dire que sauf cas
particuliers heureusement rarissimes les
enfants n'ont absolument aucun problème
pour consommer du lait c'est seulement
une fois adulte que certaines personnes
perdre la capacité à digérer le lactose
et donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'intolérance au lactose
alors est-ce que ça touche beaucoup de
monde eh bien il faut savoir qu'à
l'échelle de la planète
deux tiers des adultes sont intolérants
au lactose
j'ai bien dit les deux tiers c'est à
dire que l'intolérance au lactose c'est
pas du tout une maladie c'est la norme
et si vous pouvez toujours digérer le
lactose alors vous faites partie du
tiers des anormaux et on va voir
exactement ce qu'il faut entendre par là
voyons d'abord le mécanisme de
l'intolérance au lactose le lactose
chimiquement part lancé un sucre comme
le glucose le saccharose le fructose
tous les trucs en rose et il s'agit
d'une molécule relativement gros c'est
donc elle a besoin d'être découpée pour
pouvoir passer de l'intestin vers le
sang et dans le métabolisme la plupart
des jobs de découpe sont assurés par des
enzymes et donc dans le cas du lactose
il ya une enzyme qu'on appelle la
lactase et dont le travail c'est de
couper le lactose en deux pour qu'ils
puissent ensuite passer de l'intestin
vers le sang et à fra similé alors la
lactase elle est évidemment produite
chez les enfants et c'est ce qui leur
permet d'assimiler le lactose mais chez
les gens normaux
la production de lactase cesse vers
l'âge de six habitants et le lactose ne
peut plus être digérée alors on pourrait
penser que c'est pas très grave si
lactose n'est pas digérée après tout
c'est pas comme une allergie ou il ya
une réaction du système immunitaire
mais le lactose que vous ne digérait pas
eh bien les bactéries de votre flore
intestinale s'en charge et quand elles
font ça il ya un phénomène de
fermentation qui libère un certain
nombre de gaz comme du méthane de
l'hydrogène du dioxyde de carbone et ça
ça provoque un certain nombre de
troubles digestifs pas très cool comme
des diarrhées et des vomissements et je
vous épargne tous les symptômes
heureusement pour les intolérants les
différents produits laitiers contiennent
des quantités variables de lactose le
lait et la crème en contiennent pas mal
évidemment les yaourts un peu moins
parce que les bactéries qu'il ya dedans
peuvent déjà avoir partiellement
découper le lactose et les fromages
peuvent en contenir assez peu parce que
le lactose est soluble dans l'eau et il
s'en va quand on écoute les fromages
pendant leur fabrication
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'un tiers des
gens sont toujours capables de digérer
le lactose et bien tout simplement parce
que même à l'âge adulte
il continue de produire la lactase on
parle pour eux de persistance de la
lactase mais ça je vous le dis ça fait
un petit
figure d'anomalie puisque déjà chez
l'être humain c'est le cas minoritaire
mais alors chez les animaux c'est encore
pire puisque tous les mammifères
après le sevrage cesse de produire la
lactase et donc par exemple même les
vaches sont intolérantes au lactose qui
égale un peu cocasse alors pour mieux
comprendre le phénomène de persistance
de la lactase chez l'être humain
c'est intéressant de regarder la
répartition géographique de la capacité
à boire du lait sur cette carte on a
représenté le pourcentage des gens qui
sont toujours capables de digérer le
lactose sur les différents continents et
vous voyez qu'il ya d'énormes disparités
géographiques en rouge c'est les régions
où on est proche de 100% de persistance
de la lactase comme en europe du nord et
en bleu les régions où quasiment tout le
monde et intolérants au lactose comme en
asie alors c'est pas très étonnant que
les européens aient longtemps pensé que
l'intolérance au lactose était une
maladie puisque chez eux c'est
relativement rare mais vous voyez qu au
niveau mondial eh ben c'est le contraire
quand on voit des disparités
géographiques comme ça ça suggère
fortement une cause génétique
non c'est pas très surprenant puisque je
vous expliquais que la lactase c'est une
enzyme est comme la plupart des enzymes
elle est produite à partir des
informations qui sont contenues dans
l'adn
il ya un gène de la lactase et se gênent
et bien il cesse d'être lu chez les
adultes normaux et donc la lactase n'est
plus produite alors en analysant le
génome de ceux qui sont toujours
capables de digérer lactose des
chercheurs se sont rendu compte qu'ils
avaient tous une petite mutation dans
leur adn dans cette mutation elle est
même pas dans le gène de la lactase elle
est un chouïa en amont et on suppose
qu'elle pourrait faciliter la lecture de
ce gène est donc elle pour expliquer que
ces personnes à l'âge adulte elle
continue de produire la lactase cette
mutation il en existe en fait plusieurs
variantes
mais la principale qu'on trouve
notamment en europe les chercheurs ont
essayé de déterminer où et quand elle
était apparue pour la première fois et
d'après leurs estimations elle serait
apparue pour la première fois en europe
centrale
il ya environ cinq à dix mille ans cinq
à dix mille ans c'est vraiment très très
récent à l'échelle de l'évolution
humaine
je vous rappelle la lignée humaine s'est
séparée de celle du chimpanzé il ya
environ sept millions d'années et notre
espèce homo sapiens existe depuis au
moins deux cent mille ans donc 5 me
lancer vraiment pas beaucoup en
génétique quand une mutation se répand
dans une population il peut y avoir
plusieurs causes mais quand elle se
répand chez un tiers des individus et
même 90 % dans certaines régions et ce
en seulement quelques centaines de
générations
il peut y avoir qu'une explication un
effet de sélection naturelle positive
énorme
c'est à dire que les gens qui avaient
cette mutation ils ont bénéficié d'un
avantage monstrueux pour survivre par
rapport à leurs petits copains qui
l'avait pas il ya plusieurs hypothèses
pour expliquer l'avantagé volutes if que
confère la persistance de la lactase une
de ces hypothèses c'est le rôle de la
vitamine d vous savez que homo sapiens
est né en afrique mais ensuite il a
migré sur les différents continents et
donc dans certaines régions notamment en
europe
il a trouvé quand même beaucoup moins de
soleil or on sait que le soleil joue un
rôle essentiel dans la production de
vitamine d one soleil - de vitamine d
est donc puisque le lait contient un
tout petit peu de vitamine d on peut
penser que ce qu'ils avaient la capacité
de continuer à boire du lait même à
l'âge adulte ils ont pu partiellement
compensé leur carence en vitamine d est
donc mieux survivre que les autres
notamment dans ces régions
une autre hypothèse c'est peut-être tout
simplement que ceux qui avaient la
capacité à continuer à boire du lait
s'en sont mieux tirés que les autres
quand il ya eu des périodes de famine ou
de mauvaises récoltes
alors même si le mécanisme est pas
complètement clair ce qui est sûr c'est
que pour que cet effet de sélection
naturelle positive puisse avoir lieu
il fallait que les populations
concernées aient accès à une source de
l'est et donc il fallait qu'elle est
l'élevage du bétail et donc on a un cas
tout à fait étonnant d'évolution
conjointe qui est génétique et culturel
puisqu'il a fallu avoir à la fois la
mutation génétique et la pratique
culturelle pour que la persistance de la
lactase ait des effets bénéfiques
alors on entend souvent que boire du
lait à l'âge adulte c'est mauvais pour
la santé c'est pas naturel
alors on peut effectivement dire que
c'est pas naturel puisqu'on est la seule
espèce à le faire mais on peut
difficilement dire que c'est mauvais
pour la santé
songez que chez nos ancêtres ceux qui
avait cette capacité à boire du lait à
l'âge adulte
ça leur a donné un [ __ ] davantage
évolutif à tel point qu'on pense que
c'est même l'effet de sélection
naturelle positive le plus important
qu'on ait jamais observée dans notre
espèce l'autre leçon intéressante de
cette histoire c'est que contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait parfois penser
l'espèce humaine continue d'évoluer
l'homo sapiens d'aujourd'hui est pas le
même que l'homo sapiens gay à 5000 ans
et les vraisemblable que dans les cinq
prochaines années on verra encore
d'autres évolution génétique et
culturelle comme celle ci merci d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo si elle vous a plu
surtout n'hésitez pas à la partager on
met d'ailleurs à connaître la chaîne
si vous n'aimez pas le lait vous pouvez
notamment allé voir mes autres vidéos
sur le pastis ou sur l'eau et vous
pouvez me retrouver sur facebook sur
twitter et sur mon blog s'appelle
science étonnante
merci et à bientôt